When we started getting all that money funneling into the country.
After the end of world war II and the social Democrats were like,
look at us how good socialism is working. And it had nothing to do with them.
In fact, their policies, big government policies, um,
wasted all that money. And you know, in the 1990s,
we actually had to devaluate our currency.
I guess 30% of everything was lost because of the welfare state.
They built up.
If you listen to our, uh,
socialist Democrats or democratic socialists or whatever the hell they are these
days, I keep saying they're going to drop the Democrat part soon enough.
What they always say is we should be more like Sweden. AOC says this.
Bernie says this. I doubt that AOC has ever been to Sweden.
Perhaps Bernie has been to Sweden, but they say the Nordic countries usually,
but it's specifically, we should be more like Sweden.
Now you guys have 10 million people. We have 350 million people.
We have people from every walk of life, from every corner of the earth.
You guys mainly we're a homogenous society into the last couple of years.
There's all sorts of reasons that that analogy doesn't quite make sense.
But when you hear that America should be more like Sweden.
Nothing pushes my buttons than when I hear stuff like that. You know?
And this comes out of the mouth of what Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
let's clear this up once. And for all,
Sweden was never a socialist country in the sense that the Eastern block
was, you know, Soviet union so forth. When Sweden became wealthy,
this was during the last part of the 18 hundreds.
We had a bunch of laissez-faire reforms done. And so we that's,
when we started as a transformation to industrialize,
we were actually quite late to the game. It was these, you know,
market free market reforms, right?
When you got the government out, laissez Faire,
suddenly the economy starts booming. Okay.
[Inaudible] is the name of the guy that was very forward thinking that that made
these reforms possible.
And then things started getting better and better after that.
The other thing you need to remember is that when we started getting all that
money funneling into the country,
after the end of world war II and the social Democrats were like,
look at us how good socialism is working. Yes.
And it had nothing to do with them. In fact, their policies,
big government policies, um, wasted all that money. And,
you know, in the 1990s,
we actually had to devaluate our currency against the 30% of everything
was lost because of the welfare state they built up.
So if you hear Bernie Sanders or Warren say stuff like we need
to be more like Sweden, well, the park they're missing it stuff.
What was good about Sweden was free market oriented. What was bad about Sweden?
We, we turned out into a decent country in spite of socialism.
Not because of.
Can, can you add to that? I can confirm.
That that is true. And you can look it up. It's factual. Yes.
When you guys hear that and doing what you were doing, I mean,
as he just makes your head spin, sort of feel like you're going to smack them.
Well, I love my job. I really do. Um, because, uh,
I get to people off and I believe what Larry David once said that if you have
the opportunity to annoy someone, you should take it. Uh,
and you are doing that.
Yeah, you're doing just fine.
But do you think part of the issue here is that the exterior of Sweden looks a
certain way? So for example, uh, I had two trips to Sweden,
to Stockholm and I was only in Stockholm.
So what I'm seeing is a very snapshot version,
but just from walking around Stockholm, or maybe what we see in the media, if,
or in the movies, if they show from someone from Sweden,
they're always very tall, they look very good. You know, they're,
they're blonde like you in their, uh, in nice jackets.
And what I noticed from walking around and Stockholm was it looked like everyone
bought their clothes that morning, everyone looked fantastic. They,
everything was clean. The streets were clean. All of those things. Now I get it.
It's a very small little micro version of this,
but is that part of the problem that the veneer of this somehow is still selling
well or something like that outside of your borders?
Absolutely. Uh, I think it's a sort of a Potemkin village.
If you know what that is, there's a, it's a backdrop and behind it, well,
it reminds me of Hollywood that way. Uh, yeah. If you,
if you look at it and informed, it looks good,
but if you look behind the curtain, you, but you don't hide your homeless,
we would hide them. Yeah. Now we can't afford the hide them anymore.
Well,
we can't hide them anymore because you're here in California where there pretty
much.
Yeah, I have, I have noticed. Yeah. Uh, so no,
but I think just like not speaking out against things you might see as
wrong or incorrect, uh,
it is very important that everything looks good. If you are to have, uh,
a culture of silence and the quasi socialist state.
Or how are you guys able to gauge how much effect you're actually having on the
average Swede.
I'd say judging by the reactions we're getting from our enemies, uh,
things are going very well. Uh, they get very upset, you know,
funnily enough, like the extreme left people,
they usually do not touch me.
It is the social liberals who are sort of supposed to be like center. Right?
Explain a little bit how,
what the differentiation there is for an American perspective,
because I think Americans here that the social liberals and the far left,
that sounds sort of like the same.
Oh, of course. Yes. Liberal here means a lefty. Whereas in Europe,
the word liberal is moving that direction in Europe as well. Uh,
but it still means more like the classical Austrian liberalism.
I'm a European liberal. Yeah. Right. Something like that. Yeah.
Yeah. Me too. That's I, I would use the word, you know, fiscally conservative,
but socially liberal to describe myself. Yeah. Um,
so that's where most of the attacks are coming from on my end, you know,
from journalists, you know, people have platform, establishment media platforms,
they will be very upset and they will find a single word that don't own,
like in a sentence, pull it out and start a tweet store. You know,
they will tell you things like, well, you're dangerous,
you're a populistic alarmist. Um,
you're not taking responsibility for what kind of people you take on your,
to your show. And, you know,
going back to this thing with a Canary in the coal mine,
this is the thing because what all of these people have been doing is
working so very,
very hard at guiding the population to the correct moral
standpoint at the end of whatever they produce. And when you don't do that,
you bring somebody else on the show and say, okay,
this is a completely different perspective and I'm not going to attack you.
I don't want to fight you.
I want to explore your idea and just see what I make of it. They hate it.
They do not.
Yeah.
Is there anyone politically that is echoing some of your sentiments
about what's happening in Sweden?
Well, honey, if Bali does the job from time to time, when it, his part,
he doesn't try to reign him in which he's part of the moderate party.
Which is right-wing the other would be by American standards.
That would be like light.
Well.
What type of policies would they have just cause I'm trying to get the math,
right.
Lower taxes, more personal responsibility and individual choice.
They're trying to get it in there, but basically be a conservative or liberal
socially. Yeah. I think they call themselves liberal conservatives, liberal,
conservative. Yeah.
That sort of made that jives with me, I suppose.
So I told you guys that when I was in Stockholm for the two shows with Jordan
Peterson and I saw you there, um, that they really stuck out. Well,
first off I was ex I was particularly excited about them because I knew that
this small country was my fifth most watched country. And I was like,
what the hell is going on here? So I sorta,
and Jordan also knew that a huge percentage of his viewership was from there.
So we both sort of had that date, that first Stockholm date in our minds,
it's something special is happening. The shows were incredible.
The first show sold out literally in a minute,
which is why we added the second show. The audiences were, were phenomenal,
correct me if I'm, [inaudible].
So popular, there was a black market trading and tickets to Europe.
I would like to say that it was Jordan. That was very popular.
So just for the record. But, um, the thing that,
that truly struck me was that after the show we would do our meet and greets and
Jordan would meet with hundreds of people. Mine,
we would just quickly sell them basically right before the show.
So I'd usually get, you know,
30 or 40 people because we have to do it very quick. But at the,
at the two stock home shows we had about 80 or a hundred people.
We jammed all of these people into a small room.
We're sitting there and it felt like something memorable to me.
It felt everyone in that they had questions for.
You. You weren't them. They had prepared for you.
Everyone in that room had something written down or something on their phone or
something they wanted to hand to me or a book that I should read or a story or
something. And it was, it was so moving to me that I think I said to you, is,
is there a bar around here we can go to?
And we took everybody and we went to a bar and we hung out for hours and I met
some until they closed.
They kicked us out and I met some of the Swedish intellectuals that you guys
hang out with and all these people. Anyway,
I'm not even asking a question here suffice to say that it was so obvious to me
that, that something is going on. And you could just.
Apart from having like an,
a disproportionate amount of viewers for such a small country of your show, uh,
and Jordan's, uh, videos, uh, well you caused quite a splash.
We're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about international
issues instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.